hey guys I'm Alana and welcome to my
channel this is my second travel vlog
I'm going to San Antonio today for pack
South the first ever pack South so I
just bought myself some comfort
chocolate and off to San Antonio we go
hello San Antonio we have arrived at the
hotel I'm gonna go and get some drinks
with some friends now or I could just
stay inside and sleep yeah let's go with
that
so it's time for packs day one I slept
in in the hotel bar just because I'm
actually extremely sick and my GPS is
not working so I'm just gonna try and
figure out where to go I hope I don't
get horribly lost in this city that I've
never been to before it is a miserable
ass day it's also really call
so I managed to get my pass sometimes
it's really hard because in forces don't
know where to tell you to go but I'm
actually a special guest I think that
people at the twitch booth are yelling
about things because that's what they do
but yeah let's go have a look at
everything so impact South is basically
the same as pax Australia from what I
can see here plenty of videogame booths
largely actually anyone's here than a
tabletop area at the back of this hole
and some PC and console sections in
other rooms as well as panels pretty
much all day every day and they're in
separate theaters too pax is easily the
most interactive game convention I've
been to less waiting in lines for tiny
chunks of big releases and world
community interaction and they are
closing down its Soviet same convention
so packs day 1 is now complete I'm just
about to head to the saints row get out
of hell
slash loot crate launch party after
party and then to the twitch after party
they probably won't film those because
I'll be drinking and I feel like it
would turn out horribly so we're trying
to find the twitch out party right now
this is Kyle from Destructoid he also
doesn't know where to go it's just lost
what pretty well pretty lost but
hopefully we can find it
harmed by the river right here I don't
get this this is like a murder River in
the in Texas and San Antonio right now
this is where the push people into the
river it is time today to I ended up
filming some stuff last night but I'm
still not sure if I'll show you guys
that because it was all ridiculous but
if I do show it to you then you've
already seen it in which case I'm sorry
it's good so this lovely place is what
my friend was referring through as a
moat over the last night because it was
really dark and it was convinced that
this is where you would drop a dead body
you could killed someone
it's the final day of pack South today
I've pretty much seen everything that I
think that I want to see but obviously
I'll still go down and maybe play some
more Super Smash Bros and just slaughter
some kids because that sounds like fun
this one is one of the console sections
where people will just straight up
hanging out together playing Super Smash
Bros and you bet I'm gonna join in team
cavi forever though I'm also pretty
funny bike it's mostly we use here and I
just love that this is a thing you can
basically jump on with any group of
complete strangers and have an awesome
time and this runs through the entire
weekend it is really hard to get bored
at PAX and everyone is so nice so for my
final day I thought I'd check out the
Omega phone which is what people are
lighting up for here I'm pre-drill a
megaphone is where pax picks a few
random ticket holders to compete in a
videogame tournament they're playing
operation today though there are still
two rounds to go with the portal up next
actually people get super involved
because as eliminations and everything
and it's really awesome to watch
ah people just got eliminated I think
that's it for my birthday at PAX pretty
much saw everything I wanted only wish I
could have seen my panels but had a
little fun overall
so I just worked out of pack south for
the final day but I head to the airport
now
I don't know kind of sad but really
really excited to check out what PAX
East is like because South was smaller
than Australia so I was expecting
something huge and it wasn't really so
hopefully the next one is kind of more
what I'm expecting from these giant
American pack sedans so in back in
California I basically just played the
Phoenix right and Professor Layton game
until my 30s died and then slept on the
planes and I have to be up at like 6:00
tomorrow for an EI event so hopefully
you guys enjoyed it this vlog I'm alone
thank you for watching and I'll see you
guys next time